[Música]
algunos metros de su embarcación y
delfines acompañan a clima niego en su
larga travesía por el océano un
reencuentro bienvenido aunque breve tras
varias semanas de soledad y cuando no
son los delfines el pedazo de tierra más
pequeño puede dar una alegría como para
este regatista finlandés que acaba de
pasar muy cerca de las mismas antípodas
a lo lejos de nueva zelanda
estoy contento de volver a ver el sol
hace ocho semanas que no veía tierra y
se siente como algo increíble genial
ya son dos meses desde que los
participantes de la banda globo
comenzaron este gigantesco viaje por los
mares y el francés en el kursaal se
encuentra justo en medio del pacífico
rumbo al cabo de hornos en la patagonia
chilena una zona conocida por su peligro
la marea está agitada está blanco por
todas partes hay ráfagas de 40 nudos
aquí hay entre 35 y 40 nudos después de
la salida a comienzos de noviembre se
espera que las primeras embarcaciones en
regresen
ale sables d'olonne también el que fue
el punto de partida dentro de unos
quince días